As usual, there's a lot of great new stuff
heading to Netflix in April, and we've cherry-picked
the best of the best out of the streaming
giant's list of upcoming releases.
From apocalyptic horror to quirky indie comedies,
here are the best Netflix releases for April
2019.
Based on the 1960s Japanese show, Ultraman
is an updated take on the giant robot warrior
hero, changing the style from live action
to gorgeous 3D that'll no doubt offer plenty
of opportunity to showcase Ultraman's ambitious
storylines.
The Netflix show takes its story from a manga
that began in 2011, which introduces the son
of the original Ultraman taking up the mantle
of the hero to defend the Earth.
Remember how each episode of the original
series climaxed with a giant monster fight
that threatened to destroy towns, cities,
and sometimes even entire stretches of empty
woodland?
It'll be a lot like that, but instead of rubber
suits and miniatures, Netflix's Ultraman will
be action on a cosmic scale.
"Ultraman is here!
Glad to hear it.
My wish was heard, I guess!"
Ultraman transforms on Netflix on April 1st.
The first part of The Chilling Adventures
of Sabrina was one of the most anticipated
new Netflix shows of October 2018.
Starring Kiernan Shipka as the half-witch
Sabrina Spellman, the show quickly dove into
some dark corners of Sabrina's world.
The second part of The Chilling Adventures
of Sabrina is bound to offer just as much
intrigue, and if the latest trailer is any
indication, it's going even darker than the
first part.
Get set to be bewitched on April 5.
Through eye-opening documentaries like The
Living Planet, Life, and Planet Earth, the
BBC has introduced the natural world to millions,
all of it accompanied by the distinctive narration
of David Attenborough.
"Very impressive, but no one is watching."
With Our Planet, the team that created BBC's
Planet Earth is set to deliver another breathtaking
glimpse into the wild world that most people
never get a chance to see, and David Attenborough
is back as the narrator to guide us through
it all.
If you're a fan of nature documentaries, make
sure you tune in for Our Planet on April 5th.
In its first two seasons, Netflix's period
series-slash-documentary Roman Empire didn't
exactly blow anyone away with its historical
accuracy.
It's composed of a strange, sometimes jarring
mashup of History Channel-style documentary,
talking heads and all, mixed with dramatic
reenactments.
But while the mix of history and drama isn't
for everyone, there's no doubt that Roman
Empire is entertaining.
The third season will focus on Emperor Caligula,
and is sure to offer plenty for fans to enjoy.
Travel back in time when Caligula: The Mad
Emperor debuts on April 5.
The acting team of Brie Larson and Samuel
L. Jackson may seem like a recent development,
but the two have actually shared plenty of
screen time over the years.
After appearing together in Kong: Skull Island,
Jackson signed up for a role in Larson's directorial
debut, Unicorn Store.
The film is about a middle-aged woman who's
going through a personal crisis when a mysterious
man invites her to...a unicorn store.
Or something.
Although it was released in 2017, Unicorn
Store fell off the radar after its premiere
at the Toronto International Film Festival.
Fortunately, the store didn't close its doors
for good, because Netflix later picked up
the distribution rights.
Take a look and figure out what's what when
Unicorn Store opens on April 5th.
Netflix's upcoming You vs. Wild is sort of
a mashup of Man vs. Wild and Black Mirror:
Bandersnatch, which offered a modern update
on the "Choose your own adventure" story format.
In Bandersnatch, viewers were presented with
options that dictated where the story went.
So picture that, but with you getting to decide
if Bear Grylls jumps off a waterfall or uses
an old tree to climb down, or whatever.
“(Bear yelling over a waterfall and there’s
no way anyone can understand him)”
It's aimed at the younger audience, but if
Netflix can pull it off, You vs. Wild could
easily shape up to be a lot of fun for people
of all ages.
Take the leap on April 10th.
Say what you will about zombies, but they
just won't stay dead.
Black Summer is poised to be the next big
zombie series on the small screen, taking
audiences back to the opening days of a zombie
apocalypse.
Set to be a spinoff to SyFy's zombie show
Z Nation, Black Summer has a lot of potential
for fans of the genre.
Basically, it's the same apocalypse but with
different characters.
Take a look when Black Summer arrives on April
11th.
Based on the 2015 novel, The Silence probably
has a familiar premise to anyone who's seen
A Quiet Place a group of people are trying
to stay alive in a world infested by monsters
who hunt by sound.
But surface similarities aside, there are
a lot of new ideas in The Silence that are
going to make it worth watching.
The story centers on a young woman, played
by Sabrina's Kiernan Shipka, who winds up
on the wrong side of a gang of cultists.
Check it out on April 12.
Set in Istanbul, The Protector is about a
man who gains mystical powers through a magical
shirt and becomes the protector of the city.
But as the opening shot explains...
"This is no fairy tale."
The first 10-episode season of The Protector
dropped in December 2018 to positive reviews,
which was good news for Netflix, since they'd
already ordered a second season of the show.
Look for that to hit on April 26th.
Out of all the myths that have sprung up over
the years about famous musicians, the story
of blues musician Robert Johnson meeting the
devil at a Mississippi crossroads is one of
the most fascinating.
As the legend goes, Johnson took his guitar
and went out to the crossroads at midnight,
where the devil tuned his guitar for him and
gave him the bluesiest skills in the country
in exchange for his soul.
Obviously, that's all just a myth, but Netflix's
upcoming ReMastered: Devil at the Crossroads,
will dig into the story, as well as the real
facts surrounding Johnson's life, death, and
music.
Look for it on April 26th.
For foodies, the Netflix cooking show Chef's
Table came in like an eight-course dinner
mouth-watering and satisfying.
Now, the creators of Chef's Table are back
with an all new travel and cooking docuseries
called Street Food.
As the title suggests, the team will tour
the globe to focus on the unsung masters of
these street-level culinary feasts.
Most of the details about the show are still
marinating in secrecy, so we'll just have
to wait to hear more about how Street Food
will pan out.
We do know that you'll be able to dig in when
the series debuts on Netflix on April 26th.
Fans of the supernatural will definitely have
the most to look forward to this April.
In addition to continuing series like The
Chilling Adventures of Sabrina and The Protector,
Netflix will be debuting an all-new supernatural
horror show called Chambers.
Although Netflix hasn't released many details
for Chambers yet, the premise is intriguing:
after a girl undergoes a heart transplant,
her personality takes a dark turn.
She comes to find out that she's manifesting
the characteristics of her heart's donor.
It's a plot so original we've never seen it
before...well, at least since that one time
they did it on an episode of Eerie, Indiana
in 1991.
"I think it's my heart.
Feels kinda weird…"
Take a look when Chambers premieres sometime
in April.
Keep your eyes peeled for two new stand-up
comedy specials this month.
First, we'll be graced with yet another Kevin
Hart special in Irresponsible, debuting on
April 2nd.
At the end of the month, you'll be able to
laugh at the dry comedy in Anthony Jeselnik
Fire in the Maternity Ward.
Look for that on April 30th.
That does it for the best Netflix originals
landing in April 2019, so let's turn to the
other great movies you can look forward to
next month.
Netflix's list of new action movies is slim,
but it's full of winners.
On the first, look for Snatch, I Am Legend,
and Valkyrie, a World War II action thriller
starring Tom Cruise as the Nazi colonel who
led an assassination plot against Hitler.
Also, don't miss the cult sci-fi action extravaganza
The Fifth Element.
We'll put it this way: If you've never seen
it, you have no idea what you're missing.
"Hi,"
"Unbelievable!"
You'll also get slashers galore in April,
with Freddy vs. Jason, Friday the 13th, and
Texas Chainsaw 3D.
While most of Netflix's films are arriving
in a single dump on the first, the drama selection
will be spread out over the course of the
month.
Tune in for classics like All the President's
Men and Bonnie and Clyde on March 1st, followed
by The Hateful Eight: The Extended Version
on April 25.
Because the three hour theatrical version
just wasn't long enough!
There are even a few gems hiding in Netflix's
comedy releases for April.
If you haven't seen 2001's Evolution, that's
definitely worth a watch, if for no other
reason than to see what this bit is all about:
"Here birdy birdy birdy"
"kuh-caw, kuh-caw."
And of course you can't go wrong with Pineapple
Express, the blockbuster comedy from Judd
Apatow about a group of stoners who get in
way over their head after witnessing a murder.
Look for both of those on the first of the
month.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.